[MUSIC PLAYING]
LUCIA SUBATIN: Hi there.
I'm Lucia Subatin, technical
lead for Google Cloud Cortex
framework, and today,
I'd like to deep dive
into the technical details
of our Cortex Data Foundation
for SAP.
From previous videos, you
know that Google Cloud Cortex
framework delivers not just
the reference architecture
to solve business
problems, but we also
deliver solution
content, templates,
and deployment accelerators.
We provide not just
the recipe, but we also
include the ingredients
and some pro tips
to make your meal as
tasty as possible.
Let's first take a look at the
ingredients for the Cortex Data
Foundation for SAP.
We start with raw table data
from an SAP, CC, or S/4HANA
system.
We want to learn the
data into BigQuery,
and we want to make
sure the data is
both consistent and
updated as frequently
as our business requires.
The records keep changing
as updates, deletes,
and inserts flow into BigQuery.
This means we need
an automated way
to process these records
that are constantly changing,
such as scripts to process
Change Data Capture, or CDC
for short.
Finally, we need to
make sure our users can
make sense of the current data,
answer business questions,
and improve decisions
with insights
powered by machine learning.
We also want to give users the
flexibility to consume insights
with their preferred reporting
tool of choice, an application
or even a spreadsheet.
So how does Google
Cloud Cortex framework
help you put these
ingredients together?
Let's take a deeper look.
We want to keep the
integrations options open,
so any tool that gets the
data into the same structure
with the same field names as in
the original SAP tables work.
If you follow an ELT pattern,
as is preferable with BigQuery,
you need a way to
distinguish which
is the latest replicated
record for reporting purposes.
This is accomplished by loading
each record with a timestamp
and an operation flag.
Once the raw data
records are in BigQuery,
you have two options
to process the data,
leveraging the provided
CDC process in scripts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The first one-- you can generate
views to scan the raw table
and pick the latest
record in real time.
This is useful when
you're replicating
data in near real time from
a tool like our BigQuery
connector for SAP
SLT and the business
wants updates reflected
as they happen.
The second option is to
use scheduled jobs in Cloud
Composer to merge or upsert
the new or updated record
in a table in a specific
frequency in batch.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This is a good option to
keep costs under control
when the business does
not plan on querying
the data in real time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Some replication tools
have embedded change data
capture processing capability
and merge the records directly
when inserting them.
In this case, you can skip the
CDC processing in BigQuery,
but we supply the
scripts just in case.
Now that we have processed
our replicated data
and have the latest
changes in BigQuery,
it's time to create some models.
Our Cortex Data Foundation has
more than 60 pre-built views
that anyone can deploy
and adjust to their needs,
and the list of modeling
objects available
will continue to grow as
we release new content.
You will find the
current list of use
on the tables
they're referencing
in the entity relationship
diagram in the GitHub
repository link below.
These views not only incorporate
SAP specific business modeling,
but they also tackle
common but technically hard
challenges to solve, such as
unit of measure and currency
conversions, and the ability
to deploy SCC and S/4 models
separately are consolidated
into a single view.
You will also find scripts
to process data in batches,
flatten hierarchies,
and consume and store
data from other sources, such
as weather or search trends,
through directed acyclic graphs.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
These scripts are ready to
be executed by Cloud Composer
within a schedule you
can customize according
to your business needs.
Everything you need to
know about the deployment
of our Cortex Data Foundation
is documented in our open source
GitHub repository.
You will find the
key starting point
is the Cloud Build file that
executes all of the steps,
from optionally providing test
data through generating change
data capture scripts to updates
tables with the latest results,
to creating the views that
provide the business logics.
After you have cloned
your repository,
you can customize parameters
to match your business needs
and available data sources.
And once your Cloud Build
deployment is complete,
you will see the data sets
you used as parameters
have been populated.
And you will find scripts
to process changes
and retrieve additional
data in the bucket
you have provisioned.
These models are foundation
to more advanced solutions.
For example, on the
Google Cloud marketplace,
you will find our Cortex
Application layer content
with sample applications for
synchronously exposing data
through REST APIs or integrating
with other applications
through pops up.
Now that you know what Cortex
Data Foundation is about,
check out the GitHub
repository link here
to deploy the data
foundation solution content.
You will find all the step
by step instructions there.
And this is just the beginning.
Subscribe to this
channel and stay
tuned to learn more about
advanced business solutions
and other exciting options like
our Microservices-based Cortex
Application layer.
[MUSIC PLAYING]